follow up work and this is of course to
work with an India and alias okay so
there's going to be a talk about
approximate counting just to give 30
seconds of boilerplate of course we'd
like to do you know actual counting on
approximate counting for all kinds of
combinatorial problems combinatorial
structures but typically every
interesting counting problem we'd like
to consider is hard if we want to solve
it exactly so instead we have to settle
for approximate konting the way I tend
to think of work in this area is that
you're either trying to count
combinatorial structures of some sort so
maybe matchings in a bipartite graph for
colorings and a bounded degree graph
something like that or you might be
trying to count satisfying assignments
of boolean functions so you have your
favorite class of boolean functions
somebody gives you a function from the
class say a specific polynomial size
deana formula or something and you want
to know roughly how many satisfying
assignments are there for this dnf or
someone gives you a linear threshold
function over the bouillon cube and you
want to estimate to high accuracy the
number of satisfying assignments that
within your threshold function so that's
the kind of problem i'll be talking
about I guess I should apologize again
that you probably notice this is neither
learning or testing approximately but I
think it has a lot of the flavor of the
kinds of things we look at and learning
and testing where we're going to be sort
of trying to study the structure of
these functions and there may be
insights in this work who knows which
could be useful for learning or testing
problems so the prompt the kinds of
functions I'll be talking about in this
talk are fairly simple functions in
particular degree two polynomial
threshold functions so the more general
definition we're going to be thinking
about functions over the boolean
hypercube so I think of f is mapping
minus 11 bits to minus 11 outcomes and a
degree deep ETF is just defined by a
degree D polynomial a multi linear
polynomial we can assume since we're
over the boolean cube and you just look
the polynomial see if it gives you a
positive or a negative value and that's
how you output a boolean value plus 1 or
minus 1 and notice that since we're over
the bouillon cube we can of course
assume that our polynomial is multi
linear in the special case I guess where
the degree is 1 we have linear threshold
functions linear separators and you can
definitely assume that the polynomial is
melt
linear in that case that was a joke but
okay okay so suppose you want to count
satisfying assignments to a ltf or a PTF
or something like that brandom is doing
random sampling is very natural tool to
have your disposal it's maybe the top
tool you might sort of think of wanting
to use so for instance consider first
this problem of counting or
approximately counting satisfying
assignments to a linear threshold
function so the input to the problem is
you're given explicitly these weights w1
through WN and this threshold parameter
theta you're given those actual values
that defines the linear separator and
you want to know roughly what fraction
of points I guess p would maybe be the
true freshman points of the boolean
hypercube that are on one particular
side of the linear separator all right
you'd like to compute that value exactly
it's known to be sharp be hard to
compute that exactly so the next best
thing you might hope for is I wouldn't
get high accuracy approximation of that
fraction of points on one side of the
separating hyperplane right the
strongest thing you'd hope for is a
multiplicative accuracy approximation
right one plus or minus epsilon times
the actual value so this was an open
question for a while alastair and ben
morris came up with a sophisticated
analysis of a random walk algorithm
which obviously uses randomness and gave
the first polynomial time approximation
scheme randomized polynomial time
approximation scheme for this problem
right they ran in some polynomial time
and n + 1 over epsilon and came up with
a value right with the accuracy that
they wanted subsequently this was a
simpler algorithm the somewhat faster
algorithm was given by Martin Dyer again
it was sort of very very much a
randomized approach to the problem he
sort of developed a clever way of
chopping off a region of a hyperplane by
region of the hypercube which was not
too much larger the red region is like
what you actually want to estimate the
size of he was able to define a region
not too much larger than the red region
so that and he was been such that you
could do random sampling from this
region so you could just count now what
fraction of the time of your points
drawn from the bigger region actually
land in the red region you know exactly
how many points are in the bigger region
that will let you figure out to high
accuracy the number of points in the red
region but again like it's it's this
kind of dart-throwing approach it very
much inherently seems
to use randomness to solve the problem
okay so these are just some examples of
how randomness can be useful for
approximately counting satisfying
assignments it turns out you don't
actually need randomness to solve this
problem for the linear threshold
function case so parikh shared Adam
Clive ins and ragu participants in this
meeting gave one algorithm for doing
this completely deterministically where
they have the sort of clever way of
approximating linear threshold functions
using branching programs dan7 kovitch is
also here santosh indirect pagoda gave a
different algorithm based on sort of a
clever dynamic programming view of the
problem so it turns out that you know
you don't actually need randomness to
solve this problem in the strongest
possible sense their algorithms run in
polynomial time about parameters and
they're completely deterministic and its
relative error for these half spaces
right so in this multiplicative accuracy
kind of guarantee so the LTF problem I
think has been completely destroyed
there's there's nothing to say could be
even wolf one above sea level she sees
it already ah that's a good question you
know because then you can make epsilon
equal to 2 to the minus end and you can
be exact prompting it was it again ah
good point yes slightly but we fit
somewhere between I retract my statement
that this problem and solved in the
absolute strongest possible sense but I
mean it's like want even poly
logarithmic or something you can get
some exposure time out of the knapsack
so it depends on whether you got it done
if it's 2 to the square root log one up
retractor attraction I mean it's a fully
polynomial time deterministic algorithm
we're usually pretty happy when we when
we get something like this ok so that
was LTFS there's nothing new to say
there in this work I'm going to be
talking about the degree to analog of
this problem so the input function now
is a quadratic polynomial Q of X instead
of a linear form and what we want to do
is again we want to come up with some
high accuracy approximation to the
number of points in the hypercube that
you know are on one side of this degree
two polynomial surface that that satisfy
the polynomial thresholds fun
so the first thing we should notice is
that this is basically going to be an
impossible problem if we want to do
multiplicative approximation we have no
chance of solving the problem as well as
these guys on the last slide solve the
LPF problem because if we could do a
multiplicative approximation that would
mean that in particular we could tell
whether the fraction of points that
satisfy the degree to PT f0 versus non
zero right but if you can do that you're
solving an np-hard problem it's very
easy if I give you a graph to write down
a degree two polynomial which exactly
captures the the cut size of the graph
right so if there's a cut of sighs at
least K than this polynomial is
satisfied by the input X corresponding
to the cut and vice versa so we have no
chance of doing multiplicative
approximation you know msn p equals R P
which we think is unlikely so instead
what should we do well if we want to
keep thinking about this problem we can
lower our standards and say okay I'm not
going to expect to get a multiplicative
approximation of the true probability
i'll just try for an additive
approximation but i'll try to come up
with some value p hat which is within an
additive 1 plus within an additive plus
or minus epsilon of the true value okay
so the good news here is that if we
don't care about using randomized
algorithm this is a pretty easy problem
right I can just draw a random
assignments see the fraction of them but
satisfy the degree to PTF and obviously
after 1 over epsilon squared many
drawers I'll get an epsilon accurate
estimate of the probability okay yeah so
if you could get a multiplicative
accuracy approximation say I could tell
you a value which is between one half of
the true probability in three halves of
the true probability right then that
that algorithm which gave me such a
multiplicatively accurate answer would
in particular tell me if an input has 0
satisfying assignments versus a nonzero
number of satisfying assignments and
they're easy reductions here's an
explicit reduction showing that if you
can do this you can determine whether
the number of cuts of sighs at least k's
so yeah I brand up randomness isn't
going to help you here unless random
this helps you solve the max Club
problem this is true even if epsilon is
yeah three quarters or something sure I
guess 1 minus epsilon approximation
would be a little weird then but yeah
even if epsilon is a billion or yeah
yeah okay
you mean for polynomials where you have
some kind of guarantee just from the
structure that yeah I haven't thought
about that my guess would be that you
can probably make the problem hard in a
range of ways like this but that's
that's a good question yeah okay so for
now for this talk what we're going to be
doing is working on additive
approximations obviously like I said you
can do this very straightforwardly with
the trivial algorithm just by doing
random sampling if you're willing to use
randomness but of course we don't want
to use randomness this is a ridiculous
solution to this problem it has nothing
to do with degree 2 polynomials you can
run the same you know randomized
algorithm for any polynomial size
circuit to estimate its fraction of
satisfying assignments right that's a
sort of a very unsatisfying answer to
this problem just to do this random
sampling so kind of the only reasonable
problem in this space trying to motivate
the actual problem we address is I think
the one that nothing may maybe not
necessarily the only reasonable problem
but to us at least it felt like the
right problem to think about if you're
interested in these degree two
polynomial threshold functions right you
shouldn't really expect to do
multiplicative approximation for the
entire class of all the great OOP etfs
if you're willing to use randomness it's
a ridiculously easy problem even for you
know far more general class of functions
boolean circuits so somehow dealing with
the deterministic approximation and this
additive accuracy requirement for your
approximation felt like the right
combination maybe the real motivation
for looking at this problem is that in
order to solve it we're going to have to
sort of really stare at degree two
polynomial threshold functions and
understand them somehow and that kind of
understanding is potentially useful for
learning for testing for all kinds of
things and I guess we like you're
randomizing things in this community so
I can now tell you the main results of
the work the main result is I think this
kind of approximation is called an EP
tasks of deterministic it's
deterministic that's in red it's an
exponential exact quantum so anybody
know DPT pts stands for
no one knows I can pick and pick up
whatever I wanted anyway it's a fixed
polynomial running time the running time
is like n to the fourth or into the
Omega plus one I think exactly and then
there's a non polynomial dependence on
the the epsilon parameter once in time
to to the poly one over epsilon the
algorithm is deterministic you give it a
degree two polynomial okay and it'll
give you an epsilon accurate estimate
for the fraction of points from the
bouillon cube that satisfied the PTF
okay so that's the guarantee i should
mention that for a particular subclass
of degree 2 pts the so-called regular
degree to pdfs where what regular means
is that each very each variables
influence on the underlying polynomials
is low a small fraction of the total the
algorithm actually is you know truly a
fully polynomial time approximation
scheme it runs in time polynomial in n
and polynomial in 1 over epsilon as long
as the polynomial Q that you're dealing
with is sufficiently regular and this is
not sort of a side benefit of the main
theorem this is really the key to the
main theorem this is the top theorem
comes from the bottom theorem okay so
what what has been done in these kinds
of questions prior to our work well I
guess the D equals 1 case instead of
degree two polynomials is just linear
threshold functions we discuss that
quite a bit already the problem has been
completely solved in this very strong
sense of relative approximation in
multiple different ways a different
approach so there have been solutions to
this kind of problem previously but they
were sort of they didn't have the same
quality quantitative or qualitative I
guess properties you can you can attack
this kind of problem of doing
deterministic approximate counting using
unconditional pseudo-random generators
right so just to remind you a
pseudo-random generator will say of size
s for a class of functions see here for
us would be degree two polynomial
threshold functions it's just an
explicit set of points a set of points
that's generated by a deterministic
algorithm which has the property that
the fraction for every function in the
class yet for every function in the
class the fraction of points in that
explicit set that satisfy the function
is very close to the true fraction of
points from the bulleen cube that
satisfy the function okay so if you have
a PRG for a class of functions that
obviously gives you a way to
deterministically do approximate
counting just by the trivial approach of
enumerated through all of the points in
your prg all the points in the set s
counting the fraction of them that
satisfy the function right it's like a
one-size-fits-all approach to doing
approximate counting it's the same
algorithm for every function in the
class it doesn't it behaves the same way
so there's been quite a bit of work in
the last four or five years on studying
unconditional pseudo-random generators
for linear threshold functions and
polynomial threshold functions I won't
walk through every detail of every every
every point on the slide but the main
thing I would like you to take away from
this is that all of these results have
if you only think about I guess yeah
let's talk we're talking about degree to
PTF so for degree to PTF so I guess this
result is relevant this result is
relevant this result is relevant and you
can see there's a polynomial in 1 over
epsilon in the exponent of n for all of
these results so what does that mean it
means that if epsilon is constant you
could do deterministic proximate
counting in some polynomial time but the
degree of that polynomial grows
polynomial e with the accuracy that you
have or another way of saying it is that
if epsilon is sub constant is a function
of n if it's something you know log log
log log on or something like 1 over log
log log log n something like that you're
not going to get polynomial time for
many of these previous results but if
you recall in our approach we have a
fixed polynomial in n running time and
the exponential dependence on epsilon is
like 2 to the poly one over epsilon okay
so we're able to handle sub constant
values of epsilon for the first time and
again some sense this shouldn't be too
surprising where our algorithm is going
to actually look at the input function
right whereas all these approaches they
don't even look at the input right it's
just the same it's the prj okay so in
the rest of the time what I hope to do
is tell you a little bit about the proof
of the main result I'll touch briefly on
this first issue of going from Gaussian
inputs to boolean inputs so the main
bulk of what we do is solving the
problem for PT FS over the Gaussian
distribution and yeah so most of what
I'll do is really this is probably the
most important sort of thing that I'll
tell you about this is the key step of
our proof in solving the Gaussian
problem but I'll first talk just briefly
about going from the Gaussian
to the boolean case ok so just up here
and this box is a restatement of the
main theorem the main theorem is that we
have this exponential in 1 over epsilon
time algorithm for dealing with
polynomial threshold functions degree to
PT FS over the boolean cube ok and this
key intermediate result which is what
gives us the main result for the
bouillon cube is an algorithm for
counting satisfying assignments of PG
degree to PT FS over the Gaussian
distribution so if sort of highlighted
the differences in red the first
difference is that the algorithm is
polynomial time in 1 over epsilon for
the Gaussian case which is kind of a
nice thing and the second thing is that
you know again we're solving this
approximate counting problem where the
input points now are drawn from the in
dimensional Gaussian instead of the
bouillon cube ok so I'll talk about how
we get this result in a little bit but
first one slide on using this result I'm
not this is the only slide I'm going to
say about how we go from the Gaussian
case to the boolean case I think because
essentially all of the guilty parties
for the relevant work or here in this
room so the first step is thanks to the
invariance principle of alkan on ryan
and christoph we know that if you have
an algorithm which solves this problem
for the gaussian case this is probably a
little misleading the way i've stated it
it's not that you get an algorithm which
solves the problem for the boolean case
for regular polynomials the algorithm
which works for the regular for the
gaussian polynomials just works as is
for regular boolean polynomial right
this is just a direct application of the
invariance principle so what do we know
we know that if we have a Gaussian
algorithm it will also work to solve the
problem for regular polynomials over the
boolean cube ok and we also have this
regularity lemma different versions of
it were proved by different people but
you basically get the same thing in both
cases which says that if you give me any
polynomial threshold function degree 2
degree D doesn't really matter over the
bouillon cube we can efficiently
deterministically decompose it into some
number of polynomial threshold functions
over the cube such that almost all of
them are regular ok so we get this is
where the exponential dependence on
epsilon comes from in the work given the
original polynomial we can stare at it
sort of start to build a decision tree
the decision tree size will be
exponential
one of our epsilon and almost a relief
of the decision tree will have like a
restricted PTF which will be actually
regular we can have it be you know as
regular as we want for some polynomial
factor or it could be close to constant
but basically if we have a regular PTF
that's going to be easy to do the
counting since we have the algorithm and
if the PDF is close to constant we can
recognize this and of course it's
trivial to do the counting if it's close
to constant okay so i'm not gonna
actually talk anymore about either of
these steps they're sort of becoming I
think standard standard steps yeah yeah
so if you look at the regularity lemma
all you have to do is yeah no no there's
no randomization you have to do things
like compute the variance of a
polynomial so you just do things like
sum of the squares of the coefficients
compute the influences it's easy yeah
yeah it's a good question though um okay
so that's all I'm going to say about
going from the Gaussian case to the
boolean case I'll talk now a bit about
kind of this key step of transforming
the input polynomial we're going to be
thinking of the problems over the
Gaussian domain so we're starting with
an arbitrary degree two polynomial and
were going to see how we can transform
it into a very nice form this form is
going to be a decoupled hunta and while
it's not going to be sort of super
crucial for this talk that we get a
decoupled hunter for an India's talk
after lunch it's going to be very
important that we get this hunt Oh
structure out of the polynomial ok so
this theorem says what it says if you
give me a degree two polynomial Q so an
arbitrary degree two polynomial we think
of it as over Gaussian inputs we can
crunch on it for a little while in
polynomial time we'll be able to output
a degree two polynomial which has this
decoupled structure when I say decoupled
notice that you never have like X I XJ
occurring in any monomial it's just your
ex I but you never have cross terms you
never have xixj in any monomial so it's
decoupled it's also a hunter this this
polynomial we're going to output cute
cute wittle depends on only poly one
over epsilon many variables where the
original polynomial depended on n
variables but solving the counting
problem for this decoupled hunter
problem till the Q is
to be just as good as solving the
original problem the key property of
Tilda q is that the fraction of
satisfying assignments but it has under
a Gaussian distribution over its you
know k constantly many variables
basically exactly matches up to an
epsilon factor the fraction of
satisfying assignments under the N
dimensional Gaussian distribution okay
so it should be clear this is going to
be a super useful thing for us because
if we can you know construct this
Gaussian hunter polynomial then I can
just deal with this and there is no end
anymore right there's no possibility of
running in super poly on time because
there literally is there is no n where
it just depends on 1 over epsilon to the
4th variables so the high-level idea of
how we do this how we prove this theorem
is via sort of a critical index type
analysis it's similar to this earlier
work giving kind of a regularity lemma
for linear threshold functions with I
think that I think that sort of thinking
of it as being very analogous to that
earlier work is the best way to approach
it so I tried to set up in this slide
and a couple of subsequent slides this
sort of analogy where the analogy stuff
is in blue so I hope this is not going
to be chewing precise I'm not going to
tell you really what problem i'm trying
to solve here what the input is what the
output is but I'm trying to get you into
a mindset so when you see blue I'm
trying to evoke the mindset of this
slide so what's the mindset of this
slide well let's think about it much
much simpler kind of setting suppose I'm
dealing with just some half space over
the boolean cube okay so it's just
defined by a bunch of weight say they're
positive weights and they're sorted from
the largest way to the smallest way w 1
through WN and they're all greater than
0 and I want to somehow analyze this
half space or say that this half space
is nice in some sense well what's a
natural way to do this I'll just start
looking at the coordinates one by one
and try to get some kind of win-win
situation out so one possibility is that
when i look at the half space i look at
the coordinates it's a regular half
space right in the sense that all of the
cord and it's the first coordinate the
largest one is already very small
compared to the overall scale of the
coordinates right if this happens then
intuitively we're in a situation that
we're very happy about because if I
think about taking WX for a random input
X we know by the central limit theorem
the various am theorem that WX is going
to be distributed like a Gaussian right
and that has to be a good situation for
us some
gaussian zar easy to handle on the other
hand if w is not regular that means that
if this first coordinate is quite large
in magnitude compared with the overall
scale then what should i do well I
should take this w1 this large weight
and sort of put it off on the side I'll
worry about dealing with it later
somehow and I think about just this
resulting linear forum / n minus 1
variables I know that it must be a lot
smaller write the 2 norm of this vector
has to be a lot less than the two norm
of the original vector because I took
out a large coordinate which was a large
fraction of the original length of the
vector so I sort of made a lot of
progress ok and in this case I have to
go back up and now look again at the I
guess I'll be looking at W to relative
to the scale of the overall things see
if its regular if its regular I'll stop
so on and so forth so you can see this
kind of process can't proceed for too
many steps if you do i guess if epsilon
is sort of our largeness parameter for
being regular non regular if i do one of
our epsilon 1 over epsilon squared many
iterations i'll have driven the to norm
of the remaining part of the polynomial
down to become some very very small
value and intuitively I should be able
to ignore this remaining bit of a linear
form because it's just has small
magnitude it can never change things by
very much okay so it's kind of this
win-win sort of situation where after
poly one over epsilon many steps for k
you're either in a situation where you
have something which looks like a hunt
over these probably one over epsilon
many variables ignoring the small tail
or you have a small number of variables
that you kind of have to deal with and
then the rest of it looks like a
Gaussian and this is also like a nice a
nice situation to be in so this was all
in some you know boolean ltf kind of
setting we're going to do something sort
of morally very similar in our degree to
PTF setting over the Gaussian
distribution so kind of a key technical
tool that will use as a recent result
from the probability literature this
theorem of Chatterjee it basically says
that if I look at a degree to PTF over
Gaussian inputs I can think about the
eigenvalues of the quadratic part of
this polynomial if the largest
eigenvalue is very small compared to
sort of the overall scale of the
polynomial then Chatterjee tells us that
the distribution of the quadratic
polynomial is going to be extremely
close actually in a very strong sense
and total variation disk
to just a distribute the distribution of
a Gaussian with the appropriate mean and
variance in particular if the two
distributions are you know close and
variation distance it'll certainly be
the case that they're closed in coma
gaurav distance and we'll get that this
Gaussian this degree two polynomial over
gaussians the fractions assignments
which satisfy it will have to be very
close to the fraction of points under a
Gaussian distribution which would
satisfy this thing okay so you do a
little bit of work on top of this more
general result of chatterjee we were
able to establish this theorem and green
and the way I want you to think you know
without getting into too many details
about this condition is that it's
analogous this you know small largest
eigenvalue condition for the degree to
polynomial over gaussians is I think
really analogous to this condition of
having in this ltf world that we just
talked about the blue stuff it's
analogous to having the vector B regular
right in both cases you sort of get that
the overall distribution is close to a
Gaussian you probably could just use
various a in here yeah yeah I think you
I think you could but okay so how's our
algorithm going to work we're all out
our algorithm is going to do kind of a
stage wise decomposition basically
exactly along the lines of what we
sketched in the linear threshold
function case the blue stuff a couple of
slides ago so one possibility is that
you're actually in the regular case in
the beginning right with the sort of
structural this this theorem of
chatterjee tells us that if you're in
that case right then the overall
distribution of the polynomial the
degree two polynomial is close to that
of a Gaussian and we're done right
you've actually achieved k equals one
you have a one who does exactly what you
want so you should be so lucky as to be
in this case the typical cases that this
won't hold right the typical case is
that the largest eigenvalue actually has
not such a tiny magnitude and that
corresponds to like having the largest
wait be not so small on the linear
threshold function kind of setting in
that case what are you going to do well
you want to again sort of set that
eigenvalue aside so we have to do some
kind of change of basis which enables us
to do this
right we're in the Scouse Ian setting so
we will I guess did I skip over this I
guess yeah the first thing we'll do
actually algorithmically is we're going
to actually estimate you know we're
approximately compute this eigenvalue
eigenvector pair that's how we can sort
of compare this eigen values magnitude
against the quantities we're interested
in so if the eigen value turns out to be
large we'll just sort of change basis to
make the eigenvector corresponding to
the Zygon value be sort of one of our
input variables right this is kind of
how we were able to achieve the
decoupling stage so if we do this sort
of change of basis we can rewrite the
polynomial so that we now have this part
corresponding to the original
eigenvector v1x corresponding to the
largest eigenvalue we have some
quadratic contribution from that some
linear contribution and then there's the
rest of the polynomial now if we had a
perfect value of the eigenvalue and we
have the perfect eigenvector this guy
this remaining polynomial wouldn't
depend it all on why wad we can't
typically get the eigenvalue exactly we
can't get the exact eigen vector but if
we approximate it to high accuracy
essentially this polynomial won't depend
on that first that first variable that
we've taken out and we can also show
that we make progress we decrease the
variance and this is a pretty easy
consequence of the fact that that first
eigenvector that first eigenvalue was
actually large was a size at least
epsilon ok so this really corresponds to
having this large first weight which we
kind of set aside in the ltf setting ok
and then we're just going to repeat the
process on the next polynomial that's
analogous to sort of worrying now about
w2 through WN and the ltf setting so the
second stage is really just the exact
same as the first stage was if we're in
the regular case then we can stop and
we're just going to output this
selection would be a Gaussian polynomial
now where we have this first variable
and then we have just a linear part from
the second variable otherwise we have to
continue again to find a new variable
which will correspond to the second
eigenvector and so on and so forth so
the same kind of argument that we had in
the simple ltf case tells us that after
not too many stages just some poly one
over epsilon many stages either will
exit the loop which means it will
actually have this decoupled hunter
polynomial or will be in a situation
where the variance of the remaining
polynomials
really small you should think of this
epsilon probably is epsilon to the 100th
or something like that right and then we
can just ignore it it's easy to show and
deal with deal with the part that we
have over here which is just this
decoupled hunta okay so that's that's a
sketch of this theorem which is kind of
small down here that we can transform
the original degree to PTF over n
variables into a poly one over epsilon
variable decoupled tanta this much much
simpler got to deal with and then I
guess the last step is just to argue
that we can in fact count satisfying
assignments for this D couple to
efficiently so I mean without doing
anything it's obvious that you can do
this in time that's independent of n
again there is no and at this point
they're just probably one over epsilon
many variables since it's a decoupled
hunter right there isn't really even any
interaction between X I and XJ and this
polynomial and it turns out you can
actually do this counting in polynomial
time I think there are multiple ways to
do this final stage algorithmically of
accounting one way you can do it is to
just discretize everything discretize
the gaussians these one over epsilon to
the 4th mini gaussians discretize the
weights of the variables then you can do
exact count enforce sort of in sort of
the discretized scenario using dynamic
programming yeah so this is just saying
exactly that if you discretize sort of
the coefficients of the polynomial you
can make them be small integers if you
discretize the Gaussian random variables
you can go to a discrete setting and now
you just have some poly one over epsilon
sort of sized object and you can do
exact count dang for this guy so the
details aren't too important of that
step and this is basically it to wrap up
what did we do we gave a deterministic
algorithm which runs in fixed polynomial
time and exponential amount of our
epsilon for deterministically counting
satisfying assignments of these degree
to PT f's it was really a polynomial
time algorithm in the Gaussian case or
the regular boolean case and this was
like the I guess k equals 1 case of the
result that in India will talk about
after lodge so after lunch an India will
tell us about how you can extend this
result to deal with counting
approximately counting the number of
satisfying assignments of say an
arbitrary boolean function
of 100 degree to PT FS something like
that so the fun the fun has barely
started but we do get to eat lunch in
the meantime okay thanks the
Chatterjee's result that special yeah we
applied it in the degree to case the
resent this motion those are just more
general well we're all we're doing here
is the degree to case of it but it's
it's formulated originally quite a bit
more generally yeah no just isn't is
also true for the gate three so four
degrees I think we feel like we can
handle the great refugees visit on duty
duty parliaments of gaussians behave
like the shoes if you have some
regularity yeah yeah we think so yeah
it's nice kind of livable it's a result
of Chatterjee no no no no the side of
chatterjee applies to like nice
functions of gaussians and we think we
can from their of something else we can
do that degree through your degree D
polynomials and thousands behave like
I've seen such set of conditions will
prepare not yet shared the same answer
no special function
correctly works for the patient's own do
you mean the no I don't think that's
correct Adam would be an expert on this
but I mean for linear threshold
functions i think the first step that
people will often say is without loss of
generality you can just reorient the
cube so that all the coefficients are
positive it doesn't it doesn't make a
difference it's just a matter of
renaming variables in the boolean cube
you save it okay it call X i minus X I
but they the result is fully it's fully
general right yeah yeah